Bui kèo đầu tiên ở trong một bà đầu mình chờ kèo phô ra, mình môi cảm xa có điều qua.
Cúng được bị ngaym ra, rất là vang vào phủ một lất bấm, bình ngoài vang.
Sọn những cái thế để rất là vò qua, sau đó hấp lý.
Cậm có việc rất chậu lại tổn gì là khoảng tầm.
Bún ninh năm trong là vang tạo, cái điểm nhận để cho các khoảng tạo này lột xáng lên.
Lát chậu lại đi mất khoảng tầm.
Hai đi bà tiếm.
Mình gái chú bình mình làm được tạm đến người chậu.
Chết thích chờ nhà mình làm đầu tiên.
Bún tạo là bối gái nó mới nả khắc biệt.
Sau với gà trời tổn, cái quất mà mình cho để mình đá vang.
Lược buồn, từ tư liên về bòn trái đáng thắc gồn.
Lối đáng chức, nhé, mình sẽ in tiên để làm vào.
Nhưng cái đáng vang này, nó này, giữ kia nó mình làm vào.
Năm trong cái qua đi, tuần mình sẽ cho những cái số phong khi.
Bởi ngại này đi, gọi cứ đều đều vào, bà đi, năm bây giờ em này.
Mà đã trên mạng, rất là những ngày vụ vạm trong đây.
Mà ngang nhất.
Cáu, hôm nay mong nà bà, cái lá hôm đi.
Dẻ lá bà có giữa vương.
Nó, nó nên đây này, nó mới y tưởng rất sáng tạm.
Mình cũng tám mua mua cây tưởng rất sống hồi.
Mình cho để bây giờ, nó để để nửa khá hôm.
Tức khu vật đến.
Cái mởi này thì sẽ làm cho, sáng tạm mới, hôm, hôm, hôm, hôm.
Hãy mởi ngồi.
Là mẹ mấm cà, năm gồi thì...
Để mà gái tám thì mình lạc phép mọi thứ.
Thì cũng không sao không cả hả?